- [Narrator] TikTok and Walmart
may seem like an unlikely match,
but right now, Walmart is
one of the U.S. companies
vying to buy a portion of
TikTok, which has dance videos.
(upbeat music)
Walmart has deals for customers.
- Whoop whoop!
- [Narrator] The potential
TikTok-Walmart deal
would satisfy the Trump
administration's new requirement
that TikTok be owned by Americans.
The sometimes viral,
short-form, video-sharing app
is currently owned by China's ByteDance.
- It was really something to me
that was not on my bingo card
for this year for Walmart,
which makes it really interesting.
It shows yet another
way that they are trying
to become more relevant to
shoppers today than Amazon.
- [Narrator] There's a
Walmart within 10 miles
of 90% of Americans.
Billions of people shop
at Walmart globally,
and it's the country's largest employer.
But online, Walmart can't keep up
with Amazon's digital presence.
This last quarter, Amazon posted a record
$96.2 billion in sales.
- That's why you see Walmart
just scrambling to grow online
and grow competence in terms
of getting people things fast,
or offering a way to buy online
and pickup in a store parking lot.
They keep trying to figure out their way
to do something that even Amazon can't do.
- [Narrator] Enter TikTok.
If all goes well, the
deal could mean that users
might eventually be able to buy items
fulfilled by Walmart in TikTok videos.
- Look at this! What is this
magical brush that he is using?
- [Narrator] Imagine being
able to buy this brush
without leaving the app
or even pausing the video.
Could this acquisition
finally give Walmart
an edge over Amazon?
And how might this deal
transform online shopping
as we know it?
(light saber humming)
TikTok and Walmart are
not the only companies
to see marketing potential
in user-created videos.
Instagram just integrated
shoppable features into IGTV,
and this kind of
recommendation-based video shopping
is already wildly popular on
apps, like Douyin, in China.
- Douyin has recently announced
they've got 600 million
daily active users,
which means most internet users in China
open Douyin every day.
- [Narrator] Matthew Brennan analyzes
the Chinese mobile internet sector,
and Douyin is ByteDance's
Chinese version of TikTok.
It already has some of the
video commerce features
that Walmart could try to
imitate with TikTok in America.
- [Matthew] They see the video
and then they can just tap to buy.
That's one form,
and the other form is
livestream e-commerce,
where people will, rather
than watch short videos,
they'll watch live stream.
- [Narrator] In the U.S.,
Amazon launched Amazon
Live a few months ago.
- We've linked it for you
so you can definitely check it out.
- [Narrator] It gives influencers
a streaming video platform
to convince consumers
to buy their products in real time.
- I'm grabbing those deals,
so you gotta grab those too.
- [Narrator] American
brands like Tommy Hilfiger
are also experimenting with
shoppable live streams.
- Always need a statement puffer.
- [Narrator] But it's
still very early days
for any form of video commerce in the U.S.
- And we want you to get involved.
- [Narrator] Developing
these new features in a way
that aligns with current
shoppers' expectations
and behaviors can be a challenge.
- Walmart buying TikTok
is definitely something
that is really different
and could leapfrog
what Amazon is currently
doing in some ways,
but of course they have to do it,
and they have to do it in
a way that consumers like
and is seamless, and they
have to build the technology
on the backend.
And those are all hard things to do.
- [Narrator] And even technical
and logistical hurdles aside,
some experts warn that a
successful marketing strategy
in one market doesn't always translate
to success in another.
- I think a lot of people assume
that the model for commerce
in China could be described
as the future of commerce
and could be taken as a better,
more modern approach to shopping.
I think it's just a different
approach to shopping,
and transplanting it into
Europe as well as in the U.S.
is not as straightforward
as most would assume.
- [Narrator] Joe Kaziukenas
collects and analyzes
leading commerce marketplace data.
He says that buying items
influencers are recommending
in videos that you're
watching for entertainment
is a more passive shopping experience
than actively searching on Etsy or Amazon
for something you've already
decided you want to own
before logging in.
- This assumption that
video shopping is the future
is being based purely on the fact
that it looks more
exciting, looks more modern.
It looks like it's taking
on the sort of features
modern phones as well as websites allow.
But that assumption
doesn't hold much ground
because the shopping we have
in the West is search-based,
and changing that
drastically is gonna take
a very, very long time.
- [Narrator] Facebook and
Amazon declined to comment,
and Walmart didn't respond
to requests for comment.
- It remains to be seen,
whether U.S. consumers are
ready to buy a lot of products
through a social media app,
but the social media companies,
the retailers, the brands,
they're betting that we already
discover a lot of products
that way through ads and
influencers and things like that,
and that we're gonna be ready
to buy if we aren't already.
- [Narrator] And for good reason.
There are over 100 million
monthly American users
on TikTok, and over 100
million American households
shop at Walmart at least once a year.
But experts say what makes each
popular in their own spaces
is no guarantee a partnership would create
a video commerce experience
enticing enough to change
how Americans already shop.
(upbeat music)